So Dude, last time I was on, I was
just about to go to Venezuela and um,
that was insane. I went and vetted
myself in the protests there. Holy Shit.
Is the media line about that too?
And then, um, they're, you know,
vices on the ground acting like bad asses.
They're embedding themselves
in the protest and being like,
look at these fucking awesome dudes.
Um,
it was basically fascist mobs tried to
land just and we got chased out of the
country and then our colleague got
shot because we dared to tell that um,
the death toll that we kept hearing
in the mainstream media that Maduro is
mowing down all these protesters,
we found out that the majority of the
deaths were actually caused by the
protesters. Like either shooting
people, lynching people alive,
burning them alive,
or doing these giant roadblock heads
where they would light giant flaming piles
of trash and people would be flying off
the freeway or getting an accidents and
shit. And so once we just reported those
facts, then this lynch mob came after us.
It was very, very scary. And look, I mean,
the media is lying about the popular
support that that Maduro's government has.
Um,
there was massive pro-government rallies
there and the country's pretty divided
where it just depends on who you talk to.
What is vice doing over there? I mean,
vice is, is an imperial arm. You should,
everyone should check out my brother's
documentary called the barriers and
imperial. Oh Dude. 100% of the u s
government, Shane Smiths and imperial.
I'm Smith. Welcome to Obama and Biden
into their office. And they were like,
BFF dude, the COO of vice was like
Obama's like spokesperson. I mean,
good friends with Shane. I know him. I
know him very well. I mean, vice repeats.
He's not an imperial guy.
I'm saying they're lying.
They're lying. They're lying. The line
not lying the line because they look,
I think Obama and Biden are war criminals.
So I don't think it's cool as a
journalist to not challenge power.
And so when you invite these people into
your office and are really buddy buddy
with them, I'm offended by that.
You're such a radical lefty. I love it.
It's trailing Obama and Biden,
a war criminals,
even though the lefties fucking
lutely even the lefties,
like what does it look so fucking they
drone king bayed drone king. Yeah.
There was definitely a lot of drone desks,
but um,
check out a very heavy agenda and my
brother's documentary just goes over kind
of a lot of stuff about vice. But I think
the problem that I have with device is,
is just like the problem that I have
with all, all other corporate media,
like we were saying,
there's always align that's uniform that
basically promotes the US empire and
promotes American exceptionalism.
Clearly you've never, when you
fucked, that's delicious. You know,
what is that best show on vice
longs world, Eddie Wong's world,
those two? What's that? Action Bronson
is fuck that. Salicious that's his show.
You know, Action Bronson has the rapper.
Oh yeah. Yeah. I haven't watched it.
Never had a human being come in
the studio and smoke more weed.
Never seen anybody smoke
nonstop.
We had an ashtray that we
took photos of it afterwards.
Like this is how much weed action
Bronson smoked while he was on a show.
I just ran into him the other day at
the UFC. He smoked like how many joints?
10 joints, easily. Big Ass joints,
big fat boys just puffed him
down to the NUB. And we were,
we were with Jamie and I were stunned.
We were like, how's he keep going?
That's my advice to vice
does have a lot of good shit.
Got a lot of the problem is that when
it comes to coverage, a foreign palsy,
I think they really missed
the boat. I then they're good
on lag. That's the thing.
It's the, it's still accept. Um, you
know, it's like anyone can kind of submit.
It's a kind of like Huffington Post.
It's like a huge tent.
I think they have a hard time filtering
everything out. I think they've gotten,
you know,
they were this radical sort of like
upstart where people hadn't heard them
before and they were doing wild shit and
they had some really cool videos, like,
like the guide to travel.
And they did that thing where they went
to Liberia and met with general butt
naked and he's explaining about eating
children and cutting their heart's
fucking insane.
So that was all Shane machine did a lot
of that stuff and that was the early
days.
But that that's I, I appreciate that,
that kind of style of journalism,
but I feel like what's missing is the
context behind it. Like just vice,
we'll go to like India and be like, fuck,
this is fucking nuts. And you're like,
well, why is there this massive
disparity? And you know, it qualities.
So it's a different style of journalism.
But I do think that they really
missed the boat on Venezuela,
Russia and Ukraine and some other
things when it comes to covering global
conflicts,
because that's just the problem with a
lot of journalism and corporate media in
general, is that you're toeing the
line because you're an American.
Just like we were talking about Israelis.
I mean, you have preconceived notions.
You have your own bias, you have your
own ethnocentric lens about world issues.
So it bleeds over into those conflicts.
And unless you're like
an internationalist,
can you see the world
from a different Lens?
But when I was on the ground in Venezuela,
I was like,
this is not what we're seeing.